Kaitlyn and Shawn have split everyone's
in Hawaii and our first bachelor promo
it's time for roses and Rose a hi
everybody i'm lauren zima
in purple yes our wonderful crew made
the background purple today a regal
color and they didn't even know I was
wearing purple but here I am guys I told
you last week we were going to do a
video on the biggest breakdowns in
franchise history but here's the thing
we had an even bigger breakdown Kaitlyn
Bristowe and Shawn booth have broken up
it's very sad and I just want to say I'm
starting out with a big glass of wine
for that reason and I want to give a
drink to them right now love them both
and I just felt that we had to do a
video on bachelor news in light of this
crazy sad news and some other things so
instead this whole segment is the
bachelor news you can booze let's get to
it
first of all Kaitlyn Bristowe what a
transition from two to one
Kaitlyn Shawn are done okay guys yes
it's sad let's take a moment
[Music]
did I let that go too long I don't know
but I really mean that moment it's tough
I can understand why couples break up
hey Linda Sean it was together for about
three years and they had talked to me so
many times in interviews about how they
wanted to have kids wedding was the top
priority but it was on their minds but
maybe they'd have kids before they even
got married they were really in recent
interviews that Caitlyn was hinting it
like starting to really look at wedding
plans and then the fans came in and
people said why aren't you on Instagram
together yes look for people who
Instagram a lot it's noticeable when
you're not instagramming a lot together
isn't it now we're going through the
timeline here back in August Caitlyn
said no the rumors are not true
just because we're not together all the
time doesn't mean we split up we are
committed and then a matter of days ago
and this was a red flag for me Shawn
went to a wedding without Caitlyn and
it's not a good sign if somebody goes to
a wedding without their significant
other you know raises an alarm bell so
the question becomes what went wrong for
one of our favorite couples for mine
very much topping above the very
favorite bachelor out of all time left
Caitlyn so funny what do you think's in
these mugs I'll give you one one guess
they don't need to guess they know they
know so we have their official statement
and they said amongst other things even
though we are partying as a couple we're
very committed to remaining friends we
have both evolved as people which is
taking us in different directions yeah
from what I am hearing part of this was
that yes
Shawn had just opened this gym in
nashville he was very committed to that
kaitlyn of course has been busy with her
podcast and a line of scrunchies in a
variety of other things and it just
seems they've grown apart and they were
both very career-focused right now and I
wish them the best and on that note what
are they been doing since the split well
Kaitlyn instagrams it we've talked her
about it a little bit on and off she's
and from the shell oh can you find a way
to work a star is born into everything
in your life Lauren I don't sing those
songs yes I can
she's off the deep end watch as she
dives and into the next phase of her
life yes
Kaitlyn she's in the recording studio
with her dad recording new music oh I'm
gonna go ahead and guess that she's
writing and singing from the pain which
is great just like ariana grande just
like Ally Lady Gaga's character from the
stars born also on Instagram Kaitlyn
saying that she's been crying a lot and
taking a boxing class and that's how you
move forward everybody let it out and
just beat it out were you guys surprised
that Shawn and Caitlin split up I do
have sources telling me it was a long
time coming that they've been working on
things that had been estranged for a
minute yeah but let me know are you
shocked oh speaking of weird transition
how's Amanda Stanton let's ask that
question of course am Anna Stanton was
involved in this incident where she was
arrested in Las Vegas but guys the very
latest and I'm just catching you up this
came out a few weeks ago but we haven't
caught you up in a while is that she did
plead not guilty on that and Amanda is
still with her man okay they were
together on Halloween dressing up with
her kids looking very happy she says
she's so thankful and grateful that she
is in her life so Amanda powering
through what I would call a weird moment
that was weird drink if it's weird mmm
you know it's weird this rose' has been
in our work refrigerator for I'm not
known amount of time to be I would say a
matter of weeks and I've never known the
answer to this question does anyone how
long does rose' last I'm still working
for me am i not picky and me too picky
I'm not speaking of Halloween we have so
many great Halloween costumes let's just
fly through them and tell me your
favorites Jojo and Jordan doing a couple
this costume I think Jordan is a mermaid
and JoJo's a squirrel
I don't know how those things relate if
I'm missing that let me know in the
comments and tell me Sarah Hyland and
Wells Adams being Taco Bell so cute so
creative so funny and witty just like
the two of them Ashley and Jared on
point with a movie reference and a
Disney Princess moment they were aladdin
and Jasmine Jade and Tanner being
characters from et not Entertainment
Tonight the extra-terrestrial
[Music]
when you google ET that comes up and
that's a problem we want entertainment
tonight guys that's where we're at what
was your favorite Halloween costume from
bachelor nation let me know in the
comments okay some big news on Halloween
transition drink every time I am
transitioning I did not know that this
video would flow so well
just like my wine does don't look at my
nails I got to get them done it's
embarrassing
going tonight they seed stop it don't
you zoom in here I know what you're
doing just zoom in on this face that
someone else made up I can't do makeup
myself Chris I can't even talk to you
about how disgusting my eyelashes aren't
any thought this I wash my hair for the
first time in a week last night TMI okay
keeping it to real on this reality TV
show recap no tricks just a treat I'm
your new bachelor for Halloween we got
our first bachelor promo yes the first
time we're seeing Colton Underwood
officially in that bachelor suit
officially surrounded by rose petals a
little weird that it was on Halloween
but I'll take it cuz the bachelors very
holiday oriented because it premieres
not long after New Year's drink for
every pun in this promo trick or treat
no tricks just a treat the boots or
chiller things of this stuff here's what
I will say excited can't wait
I have heard sources say that there is a
lot of drama happening during filming of
course you know we don't really do
spoilers if you want spoilers you can
check out reality Steve's Twitter etc
and shameless blog I just filmed a
podcast with reality Steve yes guys yes
they did so you can check that out I'm
gonna be on his podcast and we were
actually filming recording whatever
audio you know I'm used to being on
camera
[Music]
yep zoom in on that we were recording
while the news broke the Kaitlyn and
Shawn had split how meta is that just
all my worlds colliding what a non
brand's day for me I went to a wine
dinner after that so from Bachelor to a
wine dinner floor wasn't my best life
[Music]
anywho also speaking of shameless plugs
you guys just launched a show called et
live yes I've been working on this for
over a year and I couldn't tell you
about it wow that was difficult I love
to share sometimes and often too much et
live is every week day Monday through
Friday 9:00 a.m. Pacific at et live.com
or you can download the app and watch it
on your Apple TV or Amazon fire all the
over-the-top app moments we love it's so
much fun we're talking entertainment
news non-stop having fun interviews and
we'll be bringing some Bachelor people
on so please watch with me thank you I
love you guys so much moving right along
where is by the way where is Colton
season at again I will not be spoiling
but I can't tell you guys that hometowns
have wrapped some filming in Denver with
Colton has wrapped and the finale is
being can't wait can not wait the only
thing keeping me going is this video new
people
drink every time is the one from the
bachelors in Hawaii
Dean Englert is in Hawaii I texted him
some recommendations on where to go Jojo
and Becca are in Hawaii I believe
celebrating Becca's 30th birthday happy
birthday Becca Tilly but speaking of the
old and the new again a great transition
Jenna Cooper and Jordan Kimball many of
you continue to ask for updates on this
and look guys like I said before I just
am not sure how much more we're going to
get out of this scandal I think unless
Jenna moves forward in some kind of
Court situation that we're gonna kind of
let a sleeping dead dog lie here not
even sleeping this dog is dead but Jenna
and Jordan continue to be on the same
page about one thing inspirational ish
Instagram quotes so time for a new
segment it's called
just sayin with Jenna and Jordan where
they are just saying some interesting
crap Jenna saying quote serenity is not
freedom from the storm it is peace all
caps within the storms what anyway
if you or your friends this is my
favorite part and family need any help
with mitigation mold damage or
demolition visit flood pro usa.com
that's right from a very pensive quote
to a very proper ad on instagram flood
pros usa.com from mitigation or mold
damage or demolition what do you want to
demolish my heart yep mmm Jenna also by
the way posing as a bride in several
photos on Instagram
what do you think is Jenna just doing
her thing or is the thirst all too real
did she want to get noticed for that
question mark let me know what you guys
think in the comments
she's also launched a YouTube channel
will you guys be watching Jenna's
YouTube channel let me know in the
comments and let's continue our segment
with another quote from Jenna with fire
and her soul mm-hmm grace in her heart
she's saying she stands tall and locks
eyes with her demons one last time life
attempted to crush her but behold wait
for it a diamond was created and who
knows maybe I'll even end up in my own
wedding dress sometime question mark
exclamation point I refuse to give up on
love well Jenna loved the perseverance
and the flood pros USA's so she's got
fire on her soul grace in her heart
standing tall locking eyes with demons
one last time
Legg tried to crush her but a diamond
was created in one day maybe she'll have
a diamond on her finger okay moving
forward to Jordan what do you guys think
of Jenna's quotes do you agree with them
do you understand them if anybody wants
to break it down for me please let me
know I would love to know what that one
last time LOC and eyes what the demons
was like Wow
mine just pop up left and right for a
quick little staring contest so moving
on to Jordan Kimball he's been doing a
lot of hanging with the boys boys
including Kevin went chasing tar deck of
this have fun together good get back to
your friends that's the best thing to do
after a breakup from personal experience
and also you know wearing a lot of
denim-on-denim cute love it at a charity
event for the kids great spending a lot
of time in Canada there's a lot of
bachelor fans up there Jordan good get
to support me lifts I self up with a
quote from Jordan Kimball enjoy the
scenery on your travels to becoming you
I actually get that Jordan no one else
has the same journey some travels move
faster than others whether it's a tank
of gas or a boarding pass appreciate any
distance achieved in this life God it
keeps going if you get a flat it's not
the end of the world wishing smart
endeavors for all round of applause for
Jordan Kimball I mean how does he come
up with that stuff the metaphors the
puns I don't even know what type of
English device we're using at this point
but I'm gonna drink for every time you
made a pun enjoy the scenery on your
travels no one else has the same journey
some travels move faster than others
whether it's a take Castro boarding I
can't just brilliant in an honor of
Jenna and Jordans wisdom it's time for
our own philosopher to weigh in this is
on the journey with JC
okay so Janna and Jordan give us lots of
thoughts but you give so many thoughts
to all of us here in the workplace on
our lives and what we can be doing
better so I want to come to you for the
JC thought of the day what's your wisdom
of the day I would say two words move on
move on explain making any insights or
references to things from before like
maybe a wedding dress or some not so
intelligible Shakespeare quotes might
just put too much more fuel to the fire
and I would say move on do your thing
Hawaii
do your thing on your YouTube channel
and just be at peace move move on be at
peace keeping it simple that's on the
journey with JC to end our video today
you guys we have just some sexuality
thank God for something sexy we love
sexy things we love intimate things we
love sexual moments we love beautiful
people and Joe and Kendall are serving
that to us yes I don't know if grocery
store Joe has found some newfound
confidence through getting super super
fit not that it wasn't before on Dancing
with the Stars but he and Kendall are
just slaying in their Instagram photos
lately let's just drink every time
they're looking sexy and I am not
holding back on my thirst comments in
their posts love we are with them every
week on the Dancing with the Stars red
carpet after the show so you guys can
get those interviews of et online.com
it's a little late for me these days I
gotta be at work at 5:00 in the morning
uh-huh it's real everybody I'm going
from coffee to wine these days Amit is a
questionable life choice but I'm loving
and living and so happy mmm thank you
all so much for watching this week again
we put a pause on the best biggest
breakdowns in bachelor history video so
that we could bring you the bachelor
news you can booze because a lot was
happening let me know how you guys are
feeling after Kaitlyn and Shawn's
breakup are you upset are you
heartbroken all my love to the both of
them especially Kaitlyn because she is
just again one of if not my favorite
bachelorettes of all time love you all
so much leave your favorite breakdown in
the comments below if you haven't and we
will get to that next week barring any
breaking bachelors like last like this
time check me out in reality sees
podcast let me know what you think
please watch ET live and I love you all
so much bang
[Music]
oh and please let me know how long rows
they last because I'm either gonna be
feeling great
or feeling myself throw it up after this
[Music]